yeah I can put this video this is yet
another five-minute game and playing my
way from Norway further I don't know if
very often it's a very regular play at
the five-minute pool and um yeah i know
c 5 c 3 is not the most exciting opening
ever but i'd like to have something else
against to me usually plays c5 and g6
stuff which is perfectly all right for
white of course but i'd like to have
slightly different positions once in a
while I have played this c5 g6 from the
white side very often okay we got a
London system and he is played with d5
d6 this kind of setup put some is fairly
solid for black this should be six would
be the normal way to to combat that try
to exchange one pair of bishops the way
for bishop is quite a good piece
obviously you can also play Knight f6
fluster Fischer be six maybe a mess a
bit more flexible retains the option to
maybe play night g seven if necessary
okay but it takes he takes a while okay
maybe intending 96 an interesting idea
all right probably just just develop
don't think there's any special reason
to to do something fancy here ah this
year indeed you can you can try that
hmm
yeah the question is should i do
something special here just plain on the
move h4 h5 for example attacking the
knight on 36 so not easy okay obviously
we can t 5 so it's this idea hy hy h5
and chance to weaken the control of the
square now I like this idea and there
maybe I should have played it much
faster because it was pretty much clear
that i would do it anyway ok so Bishop
t6 looks like the null move to ah who is
playing this very enterprising Lee is a
creative player but I really don't think
this is good predictor evil would really
surprise me if this would be would be
good okay so h5 age 5 so if he goes back
to he needs to h5 takes on c3 at a g6
and this is terrible ok so I needs to go
back to be seven out takes III this is
not playable and maybe it is actually
because I need to take with a night on d
to Saudi takes c3 h2x do 60 takes d to
check Queen d2 this Bishop before I lose
the Queen this is this is bad ok so 92
of course I never intended to take with
a night alright so if it takes on c3
maybe I should consider to recapture
simply with the porn yeah yeah that's
probably better take g6 let's consider
this once again take 36 takes d 292 ok
but I got a Paula g6 and it's not bad
okay let's say you please h6 against
that yeah I have no I have no clear
continuation all right I need to
recapture this wasn't planned but it's
nevertheless not bad I think he's got
quite a collector pieces here it's not
so easy home to develop nite nite needs
to go to f5 this is clear really badly
it needs to go them questions or Bishop
d3 and I'll just chop it off and then
try to play on the EVO ok I also need to
make sure that I'm not so far behind on
the clock so continue here like I could
just take bishop age four and then
Castle castle short yeah but how good is
that I can also take of course on g3 if
I if I don't take on f5 myself hmm
alright
not sure bishop age who is this this is
really helping me
yeah it is a bad piece i need you i need
to get rid of that hmm an interesting
question or actually i could take and
play Queenie too what's the end game
like it's material is equal I got a very
nice post on before yeah okay so I don't
like the end game night dear be 3d four
so I have a nice square deform and he's
got the bishop on c8 is not exactly yet
he can play b6 visual basics and we'll
do that yung hee hee played that but the
bishop on a six it looks nice but it
doesn't take anything and if I managed
light to define the exchange of pair of
nights this would be excellent yeah if
you take some I pre move through the
recapture I probably evil I don't know
now what side take f5 it's not so easy
for him to to move we can play rook c8
this is maybe a good good alternative he
has ideas like walk CHC for a fun
attacking the airport the only weakness
I really have I mean real weakness i
have c 3 is a week porn from a static
point of you gotta cannot attack it I
have ideas rookie one rook age 3 III
moves like that okay I he retreated I
like this but this looks strange okay I
guess this is better because h6 is a
potential idea so should I play h6 okay
i think provoking g6 must be a must be
progress
okay night is six intending 95 and 97
mmm yeah this must be good really isn't
this good night 95 is a big threat now
and if you place 96 I anyway go down or
maybe the other night hmm yeah well okay
this looks like a nice position I'm only
among a bit a bit down on the clock but
this is not exactly your unexpected okay
I don't mind that and now here
controlling the c6 square so that the
night has no square at all se8 it's not
so bad actually 98 night cat6 but ok
this is very slow and oops I I can go
here intending Luke g7 C looks rather
check yeah check
this looks terrible yeah needs to go in
the corner and after that the question
is how to I can go to g5 there's
something better no I don't think so so
preventing work the aid I don't really
know how to win this okay it looks very
nice but how to how to actually win the
game
and I can barely leave the eighth-ranked
because of da Hye morning so i can take
jealous of rock t3 check out this is
sick ah ok but it needs to go back now
it's not it's not so terrible probably
Wow check I can get this check check
draw Alfred no let's be too mate be too
mate haha 4head Simon Cowell ah what a
game yeah gel at the end the time got me
yeah I forgot I forgot that he's got
this rookie three resource I thought
okay okay this is just just this wins
for white no doubt about that yeah the
compass on + + 3 y a bit clearer Hemis
almost stay made it here but i forgot
that he's got Luke d3 this is king king
III is just bad can't play like that and
he cannot play Bishop c4 to protect and
I just connect b5 and his he's just
busted no no way to save that the spawn
is lost whenever he knows he leaves the
eighth-ranked i played this said this is
made so it cannot allow that so he
basically has no movie him he can play
nothing moves like this I just collect
check and then it's rupee seven again
this is just playing without the king
and without the bishop the thing is what
I forgot is that in the game I just
intended to advance the king but i
forgot that check
that he's got this this check as a
saving resource and here I'm okay this
rook to e3 I need to prevent it with
Luke a7 and this is still okay for white
he still cannot move anything here the
compass actually on 000 probably am with
some repetition so you have the shame to
lose the game maybe I had some some even
more powerful way to play but it really
looked nice I mean ok if you can only
get one point per game so now I don't
know something more powerful a for now
but ok it's a win anyway if he if it
would be increment blitz this is just a
win for white alright with an
interesting game thanks for watching